Okay,
what's changing is the idea that um,
elections are controlled by a small
group of professional campaigners,
consultants and,
and,
uh,
um,
fundraisers and pollsters and the,
the big media people who kind of write
the,
the frame that's all being opened up.
And what we experienced in the United
States was the first,
uh,
what I call it,
mass participation election.
Literally millions of people waking up
every day and being involved in the
election way before election day and
mobilizing their friends in organizing
events,
in doing their own micro fundraisers in
creating their own messages and
spreading them online.
Um,
and that,
that is a new dynamic when you have out
of a country with maybe 120,
100,
30 million voters,
10 or $20 million of them that actively
involved.
It definitely changes the dynamic of
politics and the world that politicians
have to operate in.
So that's the big.